hey folks kurt here and welcome to the
game pass show where we go over
what's new what's leaving and suggest
some stuff that maybe you should
consider checking out
make sure to like and subscribe and here
is your game pass digest
for august welcome
all right first up let's talk about
what's coming to game pass over the next
couple weeks
the platforms and specific dates are
going to be listed at the lower end of
the screen
we got curse of the gods
dodgeball academia
katamari damasi re-roll one of my
personal favorites
luminesce remastered
[Music]
skate skate 3 but that's specifically
coming to the cloud
star mancer art of
rally
hades
[Music]
and lastly microsoft solitaire
collection the premium edition
now of course when new things come that
means some stuff
must go so here's your chance to check
out these games over the next couple
weeks before
they're gone leaving august 8th is grand
theft auto 5
then leaving on august 15th is ape out
crossing souls darksiders genesis
don't starve the original final fantasy
vii
and train sim world 2020 the game pass
library can
be intimidating which is a great problem
to have but
it could also be a little overwhelming
so in the next two segments
i'm gonna share what i've been playing
and a pick of the week to help
maybe give you an idea of something you
should maybe consider checking out
so what have i been playing this week i
have been playing a game called
last stop and i think it's fantastic
last up is a narrative driven choose
your own adventure game where you step
into the shoes of multiple characters
from all sorts of different walks of
life with their own
problems conflicts and relationships but
in a mysterious
twist of things their lives are more
parallel than they might believe
one of the game's crowning achievements
is its representation of
all these different characters some of
which are extremely unlikable
enforce you as a player to have to make
decisions that you
probably wouldn't morally make but it's
in putting you in the shoes of these
specific situations and giving you
perspective of these
kind of different personality traits
that makes the game
so engaging also i
never knew where it was going there was
no single moment that i was able to
properly predict or
where all that was heading in the end
and let me assure you
it goes places and no matter what you
think it is or no matter how you guess
it
i would be shocked if anybody was able
to predict
uh the conclusion of this game so don't
don't let it spoil you
don't don't don't seek spoilers even if
you saw a spoiler you probably would
still be confused
um anyways last stop big fan it's on
game pass
alright so we've gone over what i've
been playing but now this is my pick
of the week a game that i love dearly
that i think you should consider
checking out
and it's not out on game fest yet but it
will be on august 5th and yes i'm
talking about katamari demasi
re-roll katamari demasi is a cult
classic from the ps2 era and it is
without a doubt one of the most bizarre
and fantastic games
i will probably ever play so in short
you play a prince who has to rebuild
moons and stars and constellations for
the king of all cosmos
and to do that you take a ball and you
essentially just
roll things up on the planet giant
buildings
people cats if it exists you can roll it
up
and turn that thing into a star and if
that very deep plot line mechanic
doesn't compel you
one thing should and that is its
soundtrack which is
an absolute masterpiece and yes i own it
on vinyl
i'm a big fan and that wraps up this
week's episode of the game pass show
i'm your host kurt indovina and make
sure to come back
the first and third week of every month
for the game pass
show usually hosted by persia not me
she was doing halo content which is
absolutely worth it so be on the look on
our channel for halo content if halo is
a thing
that you like okay thanks for watching
thanks for being here
let me know in the comments if there's
any games you're looking forward to or
things that you want to see
as the pick of the week um here on the
gamepad show
okay really appreciate it see you later
enjoy your games because games are cool
[Music]
bye
you